would there ever be a pineapple express
2 maybe we
tried to make one and thanks to the sony
hack you could actually like find the
email when sony
decided to kill the movie and not make
it so
it was it was something we were very
open to
uh several years ago but sony was not
that interested in it
i still find drug humor weed humor
some of my favorite humor i love it and
i feel like
people are afraid to make those movies
not you
no uh but people are afraid to make
those movies for a variety of reasons
i think it has to do with they're afraid
to look stupid
probably luckily that's not a fear i
have
obviously it's a it's a tough genre i
will say also like when we made
pineapple express like there was not a
lot of great weed movies
and as we would tell people we were
making a weed action movie they looked
at us like we were [ __ ]
so stupid and crazy for the you know it
took
four or five years to write that movie
and every time they'd be like what are
you working on oh it's like a weed
action movie they'd be like
i wouldn't do that why wouldn't they
jump at the idea of
a pineapple express two if the thing
made 85 million dollars which is i i
assume a lot of money
i think we probably wanted too much
money i think like because they never
want to pay
because we made the first one no one got
paid anything and that's why it was
it was like a 25 million dollar movie
you know and that's why it became
highly highly highly profitable is
because it was made
really cheaply especially for an action
movie and then um
i think yeah i mean studios are just
they don't like giving away money
it's weird weird thing